[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning
saturday the aftermath of a tragic day
continues to haunt the city of
philadelphia
36 years ago on may 13 1985
a year's long confrontation between the
city and a black liberation organization
known as move
ended with a bombing killing nearly a
dozen people
including children now it's a merge of
the remains of some of the victims were
never returned to their families
and may have been mistreated family
members speak out about their initial
loss
and the fresh pain that's now followed
where did you live lived at 6221. see
this door here and then you see the
older door and you see the sign
how long has it been since you've been
here since i've been back to this street
i come back to this street every year
you know all of that stuff that
move was talking about police brutality
all those things are real
every day i see those kids
there's not a day that goes by where i
don't like
think about them in some way not one
mike africa junior lost his playmates
his home
and his innocence on this street 36
years ago
[Music]
it was mother's day 1985. the day
philadelphia police
dropped a bomb on three blocks of this
community
home to a group of counter culture
activists known as the move
organization i wasn't here that day
i was at my grandmother's house which is
about four miles from here
you saw the smoke it was black and you
could see like ashes
floating around the blocks were
decimated
61 homes destroyed and 11 people killed
five of them children this is
a really hard thing for me to talk about
because i feel like
i am reliving 1985.
nearly four decades later the parents of
those young victims
learned their nightmare had not ended
we are in pain we're not weak don't
misunderstand
we are not weak by no means we are very
strong thanks to the power down after
that pain triggered by a shocking
revelation
concerning their children's remains the
penn museum
the university of pennsylvania and
princeton university
had used the bones of 14 year old tree
africa
and 12 year old delicia africa for
research
and teaching without the knowledge or
consent of their family
each university apologizing for its
actions
i was in shock i'm still in shock i
couldn't believe it as far as i knew
everybody was buried but they weren't
a second set of remains thought to be
cremated four years ago
were found in a box in the medical
examiner's office
both penn and the city of philadelphia
had to be held accountable for what
happened these folks were black
these folks had dreadlocks these folks
were anti-social
so we they've done all the labeling it
takes to marginalize
them make them be less than a human
being right and so
it becomes easy to be dismissive about
them
move practice the first amendment the
right to assembly
walter palmer is an activist a lawyer
and professor of american racism at the
university of pennsylvania
nobody wanted to recognize move for
sickly city palmer was witness to the
tensions between police and move
the first police sweep through the house
was fruitless move members had hidden in
a basement
including during this 1978 standoff
when officers tried to evict members
following noise and sanitation
complaints from neighbors
an hour later as fire hoses flooded the
basement several shots rang out
answered by a barrage of police gunfire
i get caught in crossfire because the
police open up
on move i saw six policemen empty their
sub thompson machine guns
police officer james ramp was killed
during the confrontation
there's still debate over whether or not
he was the victim of friendly fire
nine move members were convicted of
third degree murder
and sentenced to more than 30 years in
prison
including mike africa junior's parents
mike
and debbie africa his mother gave birth
to him
in prison seven years later came the
horrific
firestorm leaving hundreds of people
displaced
it doesn't look anything like it did it
doesn't feel the same or anything it
really doesn't it's this whole block
the whole thing has been recast
yeah because we used to go off trail
because everybody else was on trail
lisa kate's family was not a part of
move
but their home was destroyed in the
mayhem
it was just something that you know
shouldn't have happened
really shouldn't have happened a federal
jury
found that philadelphia authorities used
excessive force against the group
and ordered the city to pay 1.5 million
dollars in damages in 1996.
i'm not hurt i'm disappointed i'm glad
it's finally over
this ain't about money this is about
taking a stand
for all people so that this government
knows
that the people ain't going to have them
bombing people
and burning people alive mayor jim
kinney
has formally apologized on behalf of the
city for the continued pain
and mishandling of the remains of the 11
victims
this is about the families this is about
the deceased this is about the children
that were never treated respectfully and
decently in 36 years
we are going to stay on the move and we
are going to push for accountability and
we are not going to stop
until we get it but mike africa is among
those
calling for an independent investigation
we believe that apology without action
is meaningless what will an
investigation bring to light that you
don't already know
i think the investigation will bring to
light
the severity of
the crime you know it's not just about a
bomb that was dropped a fire that
happened and 11 people died
it's also about a cover-up it's what we
hope to
expose and deal with
and mike africa junior says the remains
of those victims have still not been
returned to their families
after 40 years in prison he worked very
very hard to help get his parents out
there
on parole now for the crime that they
say he
that they committed and killing that
police officer 36 years later it's still
stunning to look at that file video
of that bomb drop in that neighborhood
it's hard to believe isn't it
it is michelle thank you